[Music]
today and someone mentioned accepting
research on you all kinds of research
and I found out that I'm just a perv
let's face it nobody I was reading about
you know growing up and what you know
what kind of movies you liked your
favorite movie of all time
was shot right here in this studio
Goonies last year cooties was shot in
this room there Duty fans out there my
favorite movies I grew up with that
movie and movies like Stand By Me et
it's basically just all the like cool
boy adventure movie you like the boy
it's funny because I have all these
people in my staff who are a certain age
younger than me Goonies is their Citizen
Kane it's like the greatest movie ever
made pretty much yeah so you like boy
movies well yeah or you know Indiana
Jones was was my idol I wanted to be him
I wanted to be an archaeologist because
of him really and then well might yeah
but my dad had to under he had to
explain to me that being an archeologist
means you're sitting in a pile of dirt
it's not it's not swinging on ropes with
it yeah yeah Indiana Jones is the
biggest misrepresentation of a
profession ever
blam blam that's how I can yes that's
how I guess like like middle school
that's like a middle school kiss no yeah
I was doing a bit and pretending to do
it that way
that is actually how I kiss that is my
move is I make a crazy jack-o'-lantern
face yeah stick with it my wife hasn't
lived with me for four years see you
like were you a tomboy by any chance
yeah definitely
okay like tomboy like you like to play
you like to play sports you like to any
kind of sport whatever soccer football
whatever it was I was playing with the
boys hanging out then care at all about
girly stuff did you have I mean it you
have Barbie dolls anything like that
yeah I have Barbies for a minute but
they didn't really stick around very
long I ended up I ended up mutilating
them pulling their heads off cutting off
all their hair dyeing them with markers
and sticking them on the Christmas tree
lights and they light up like these
demonic hey my parents work I've never
been more attracted to you than I am
because your your beautiful and I love
serial killers that's disturbing
behavior that's the kind of behavior
that your parent you're supposed to
report it well back then I don't think
people reported that kind of stuff now I
would definitely be do you still do that
you don't still like mutilate dolls and
stick them on your Christmas tree oh no
thank goodness I still have the heads
they still go on every year at home I
still have the heads true story when I
was a kid I broke into my sister's room
cut off all of her dolls hairs and
carved my name backwards on their
foreheads true story
I was 26 you're way more messed up than
me yeah I think so